the un's human rights body is debating
whether to launch an investigation into
Iran's brutal Crackdown against a
two-month-old anti-regime protest the
Iranian government slammed the meeting
saying Western Nations behind it lacked
the moral credibility to preach to
others on human rights
the head of the UN Human Rights Council
said 14
000 people including children have been
detained by Security Forces during two
months of protests
well the meeting was called at the
request of Germany and Iceland here's
German foreign minister annelina belbach
that is wise we are now proposing that
an independent and impartial U.N
mechanism to be established
to investigate these human rights
violations
so that those responsible can behold
accountable
because
impunity prevents
Justice
Justice for sisters Justice for Sons
Justice for mothers
they have names Gina Adu fazel minu
today is about them
today is also test of our courage here
in the United Nations
about our courage to speak out
we can now talk to Lucy mckernan she's
with Human Rights Watch where she is
deputy director for United Nations
responsible for advocacy she's in Geneva
and has just stepped out of that meeting
of the un's human rights body on Iran to
talk with us
Miss uh McKinnon thank you very much for
taking time for us first of all do you
think the Iran's Crackdown on protesters
warrants a U.N investigation and if so
why
yeah absolutely
um we strongly support the call for an
investigation
um we just heard today at the Human
Rights Council here the special
rapporteur on the situation in Iran
describe
um the possibility of accountability
within Iran as structural impunity he
described how the Judiciary was not
independent how the laws don't comply
with international human rights
standards and so it's uh impossible to
get an impartial investigation at the
domestic level
therefore we think the International
Community needs to step in with an
international investigation and that's
what we want to see the Human Rights
Council do today
how much support is there at the UN for
an investigation into human rights
violations in Iran
well we heard today that the special
session itself was supported by 51
states which is a great sign and we've
heard a lot of statements today
condemning the the situation in the
brutal Crackdown on protesters in Iran
um we'll have to see what happens when
the resolution is presented at the end
of the special session and how many
members of the Human Rights Council
support it but we're
confident we're quietly confident that
it will pass
even if a mandate for an investigation
is granted though what difference would
it make for the people in Iran
presumably Iran's government is not
going to support that investigation
that's true uh the special Apple Tour on
Iran which has been in existence for a
number of years
um has never had the cooperation of the
government of Iran so we don't expect
that Iran would support and cooperate
with an investigation established now by
the council
uh however we know you know that that's
not an uncommon situation there are many
mechanisms established by the Human
Rights Council where the country concern
does not cooperate other examples being
Myanmar North Korea and so on so um
there are other ways of course of doing
these sorts of Investigations remote
investigations So speaking to Witnesses
and victims remotely
um of course using information that's
available publicly on social media
there's lots of videos photographs
testimonies which of course need to be
verified but can be used to to do
credible investigations and the key here
of course is that this would be an
impartial and independent investigation
and so give it a great deal of
credibility
so an investigation by the U.N could
still shed light on the human rights
situation there but what can the
International Community actually do to
support those in Iran who are demanding
their basic rights
well I think the International Community
can call sessions like we've seen today
and publicly Express their condemnation
of the human rights violations that are
ongoing in Iran I think we can't
underestimate the um the how showing
that sort of solidarity to the
protesters on the ground can help um
give them a sense of support from
outside of the country at a time when
they're facing this brutal Crackdown
importantly also I think the
International Community of course can
offer a sanctuary to those who are
fleeing the persecution in Iran and
finally if this investigation is
established today by the Human Rights
Council this fact-finding Mission
um it'll be important that states then
ensure that the fact-finding mission has
the resources to carry out its work and
to support it in that way
Ms mckernan thank you very much for
talking with us that was Lucy mckernan
with Human Rights Watch in Geneva